hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve a problem
graph valid tree so this is another leak
code premium problem so we are going to
be solving it
on lint code because it's free on that
website so we are going to be leveraging
that
and also this is another problem from
the blind 75
list so this is graph valid tree so we
are going to be filling in one more
problem from that blind 75 list today
so this is a graph problem we are given
n
input nodes labeled from zero to n
minus one and we're given a list of
undirected edges the undirected means
that the edges will go both ways so you
know we have
a couple nodes like this so the edge
could go in either direction
and we just want to write a function to
check whether these edges and nodes
create
a valid tree or not so we know it's
going to be some kind of graph right
it could the graph could look something
like this right we don't care
too much about the values here but let's
say this was the shape of a graph
does this count as a tree well yeah this
is a pretty familiar looking tree right
so we would say yes this
is a tree but if i add one more edge
like
this one is this a tree it's not
a tree and the reason being is because
we have a
loop inside of this graph trees are not
allowed to have loops that's just
something that you you know you just
have to kind of know the definition of
because in this problem they don't tell
you what exactly is the definition
of a valid tree so we know trees can't
have
loops and there's one more condition for
it to be a tree a tree
needs to be connected so for example if
i had a graph that looks like
this this is not a tree because
every node is not connected right like
this node over here is just by itself
it's not connected with the rest of the
nodes
so for it to be a valid tree we can't
have
loops and every node needs to be
connected
so simply we can take our input nodes
and our edges
and then check are they connected and do
they
not have a loop and to be able to do
that so
you can see the format that we're given
our edges in but
we want to use these using these edges
create an adjacency list so basically
for each node for example you know one
we want to know what neighbors does one
have in this example
one only has a single neighbor right and
that's zero
what neighbors does two have in this
case two has a single neighbor and it's
zero that's basically what we wanna do
we wanna create a list
of neighbors for every single input node
and once we get that it'll be easy to
traverse the graph and then we can
perform our check to make sure that it
is a tree
so let's say we were given a graph like
this is this a valid tree well just by
looking at it we can tell
yes that it is but what kind of
algorithm can we do to determine that
well let's start at any node in this
graph we're always just going to choose
node 0 because it's you know the
smallest value every single graph is
going to have at least a node 0 if we
don't even have node 0 like if we if the
number of nodes
if we don't have any nodes at all then
we can return true basically an
empty graph does count as a tree
technically
but so in this case we don't have an
empty graph so we're going to start at
node
0. what are we going to check basically
we're going to do a standard
graph traversal you could do breadth
first search but i'm going to do
depth first search and so for every
single node we're basically going to go
on and visit its neighbors recursively
and then
continue to do that until we visited
every single node that's connected
to the zero node at the end what we're
going to do is
take the number of input nodes that we
were given in this case it's 5
and then we're going to check if the
number of visited nodes
matches if the number of visited nodes
matches the input value for nodes that
means that
every every node inside the graph is
connected right that's one of the things
we're looking for is
is the graph connected if the number of
nodes we visit
matches the number of nodes given to us
we can guarantee that that graph
is connected the other thing we're going
to check for is to make sure that this
graph
does not contain any cycles or loops
if we ever encounter a cycle like for
example you know we have an edge like
this
if we went here we went here we weren't
here and then we got back to zero
that counts as a cycle then we would
have to return false immediately but if
we don't reach a cycle
and this condition ends up being true
then we're going to return true
so since we start at 0 what we're going
to do is to
our set of visited nodes it's going to
be a hash set because that's the most
efficient way to do
it so we're going to add that node 0
because 0
has been visited so then we're going to
recursively go to
its first neighbor 1 so now we're going
to be at 1 right and from from the
perspective of 0
we're gonna visit one after we're done
with that we're gonna visit two then
we're gonna visit three bills first
we're gonna start at one so now we're at
one right
we're gonna go ahead and add one to the
visit set
and we notice one has two neighbors
right
it has a neighbor 0 and it also has a
neighbor
4. now one problem with our algorithm is
for every node including 1 we're always
going to want to visit
every single neighbor it has we know
that the neighbor
zero has already been visited right so
if we end up going
back here we're gonna see okay we're
visiting zero again
zero happens to be in our visit set so
that means we detected a loop
but technically this graph does not have
a
loop so how can we get around this edge
case if
every time we visit a node like one
we're going to end up going
back to where we came from and that's
always going to give us a false
positive of detecting a loop it's going
to be a false positive for a loop
how can we get rid of that well every
time we visit a node such
as 1 what we're going to give it is one
additional value
and that's going to be previous previous
is gonna be what the
previous node we just visited was
so when we get to one we're gonna say
the previous node that we
visited was zero so we're not gonna go
back
to zero from this position if there
happened
to be another way back to zero for
example let's say four
ended up connecting to zero then we
would detect a loop right
but one if we ever got to four we would
say okay the previous value
from four will happen to be one right so
this four
came from one so so we won't get any
false positives if we do it like this
so from one the only node we're gonna
visit is gonna be
the neighbor four so yes we're gonna go
to four now and we're gonna see okay is
already visited it's not so let's add it
to the visit set so
4 is going to be added as a node that's
been visited
now we know the previous node from 4
happened to be 1 right so we're never
going to go back directly to 1
we're going to skip that and we're going
to check does 4 have any other neighbors
it does not
so this is going to be our base case for
our debt for search we're going to
return
true because so far we have not
encountered a loop so we can return true
if we did encounter a loop then we would
have to return false but so far we're
good we're gonna return
and then we're gonna get to one and from
one we have no more neighbors left to
visit either so then we're gonna return
back to zero and by the way what kind of
previous value would we
feed into zero because it's going to be
the first value we end up
it's going to be the first node that we
end up visiting so we can give it a
default previous value of negative one
because we know that no nodes in the
graph are actually going to have a value
of negative one because they start at
zero
so now let's go to the next neighbor of
zero we'll go down to two
okay check has two been visited it
hasn't so let's add it to our visit set
two is being added
now two does not have any additional
neighbors it only has that neighbor that
it came from
node zero so we're we're not going to
keep going and then we're gonna go to
the last neighbor of zero we're gonna go
down to
three and once again check has three
been visited it hasn't
so then we're gonna add three to the
visit set then we're gonna go back to
zero
and then zero does not have any
additional neighbors so now we're done
we didn't detect a loop so that's good
but let's make sure that the graph
is connected it does the so the number
of input nodes we were given is always
going to be given as a parameter it was
n
equals five now let's check the length
of this visit set
because that tells us how many nodes are
connected and it happens to exactly be
five right so in this case we are going
to end up returning true
now if i change the graph let's say this
edge did not exist
of course then we would not have visited
this three node
then you know the length of our set
would have been four but the
n value was five so does n equal four
the size of our visit set no
that does not match right so therefore
in this case we would have to return
false we didn't detect a loop but
the graph is not connected so we have to
return false because it's not a valid
tree
and similarly let's say we had an
additional node from
four to zero then in our debt for search
what we would have done
is okay we have gone to zero and then
we're visiting zero so we check
is zero already in our visit set yes it
is zero is right here so that means
we're visiting
it twice that means we detected a loop
that means we return false
immediately so that's the main idea of
this algorithm
now the time complexity since we're only
you know having to traverse each node
once at most once and each edge at most
once
the overall time complexity is going to
be number of edges
plus the number of vertices or nodes so
just e
plus v and that's also going to
basically be the memory complexity as
well
because this is we're going to be doing
this recursively
and we're also going to be needing to
create an adjacency list
of connecting every single node to all
of its neighbors
and i think it'll be if it's not super
clear right now i think it'll be pretty
clear once i show you the code it's not
too bad let's get into it
so one base case is if we aren't given
any nodes at all so if n was zero so
in that case we would return true
there's no graph to traverse
but an empty graph does technically
count
as a tree and if
we do have some nodes then we're going
to create an adjacency list so
what i'm going to do isn't first of all
for every single node
in our input so basically n is the
number of nodes
so for i in range n i'm going to create
a pair
in our hash map and each pair is going
to be
the value of that node and an empty list
initially
and then i'm going to go through every
pair of
nodes in every single edge so
an edge is basically a pair of nodes
being connected right so what i'm going
to say
is and remember these edges are not
directed so they go both
ways so for the adjacency list of n1
i'm gonna append n2 to that list and
similarly for the adjacency list of n2
i'm gonna append n1 and then i'm going
to start defining our depth first search
remember we are going to pat we are
going to know which node we're visiting
so i'm going to use
i as the value of the node that we're
visiting remember we're also passing in
one other variable the previous node
that we came from so that we don't you
know get false positives
for loop detection and so you can see
i'm defining this function inside of our
outer function that just means i don't
have to pass
in the variables like adjacency list
into this
each time and actually i need to define
one more variable that's going to be
visit which is going to be a
set which is going to keep track of all
the nodes we've visited so one base case
is going to be if i is in the visit set
that means
it's already been visited that means
we've detected a loop that means we can
return
false if not that means i hasn't been
visited so then we can go ahead and add
it to visit so
let's add i and then let's go through
every single
neighbor of i so every single node let's
call it
j in the adjacency list so the list of
neighbors
of i and if j happens to be equal to the
the previous node the node that we came
from then we're going to skip
this iteration of the loop we can do
that with the continue statement
if it's not the previous node that we
came from then we're going to call debt
for search on this node j
and as the previous value we're going to
pass in i because that's where we're
coming from when we arrive at node j
now if the return value of this is
equal to false so if not the result of
this
then we're going to immediately return
false because that means we detected a
loop
if this does not return false then we're
basically going to continue we're going
to go through all the other neighbors
of the node i and if we go through every
single neighbor without returning false
then we can return
true meaning we did not detect a loop so
we want to now return the result right
and of course we know we're going to
have to call our debt for search
function we're gonna start at node 0 and
as a previous value we're going to pass
a negative 1 because negative 1 is never
going to exist
in our graph but is this enough remember
our dip for search what it's returning
as the true and false is only detecting
if there's a loop like a cycle or not
but it's not making sure that the entire
graph is connected so
we're only going to return true if this
function returns true
and if n which is the input
of the number of nodes exactly matches
the length
of the visit set basically every single
node happened to be visited that means
every node is connected
that means the graph is a tree so only
if both of these are true are we going
to return true
so this is the entire code and i can
show you if i slide this up a little bit
that this does run
and it does run pretty efficiently so i
hope that this was helpful we're
basically just doing a standard debt for
search
on this graph and if this was helpful
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching